first and foremost we have to understand
that there's no such thing as certainty
of outcome um and this is why this is
one of the this is a huge difference
between finite mindsets and infinite
mindsets right a finite minded leader
is afraid of surprises and does not like
uncertainty which is why they like to
work work in very short time frames
because you can actually affect quite a
lot of certainty if you only think
quarter to quarter maybe
year to year but if you start thinking
in five and ten year increments
we all know we have zero control over
those outcomes so finite minded players
like to play with very short time frames
because it makes them feel better even
though the game is infinite so it's
actually again sort of a stupid idea
infinite infinite-minded players embrace
uncertainty and find opportunity in
surprise and so where something goes
wrong or different and just as an aside
i got such a kick out of when kovitz
struck you know everybody was talking
about during these uncertain times
news flash all times are uncertain
there's never been a time in history
ever that was certain all that happened
was something that we didn't expect took
place that reminded us
that time is uncertain
and for the finite minded players the
immediate reaction was panic right
um what am i going to do how am i going
to survive and try to double down on the
old way of doing things hoping that if i
just did it more or at least attempt to
do it online that i would that it would
survive right the more infinite-minded
players and this has nothing to do with
stress we can still have high stress
with the with with what was going on but
the more infinite-minded players saw the
sudden change in their business and saw
and thought okay this is an opportunity
what can i do with this
and instead of doubling down on the way
they used to do things but doing it
online they said okay the times have
changed the way i operate my business
have changed all the things that i used
to be able to do like having lunch with
people can't do any more
so given what i know now if if i was
starting from scratch i have something
really valuable and important how would
i build my business today to still
provide the value to the people who are
looking for the thing that i offer and
that was their mentality their mentality
was very entrepreneurial their mentality
was very creative
and they though it may have caused
stress there was an appreciation for the
opportunity